Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and this week
on Game of Thrones Daenerys proved what a
badass she was, The Hound and Arya are hilarious
and evil as always and the aftermath of the
purple wedding gets really disturbing.
So if you’re finding me for the first time
I’m doing a weekly giveaway just to say
thank you to all you guys for being so awesome.
It’s a $20 amazon giftcard.
I’ll be picking one subscriber randomly
from the comments on this video and announcing
the winner in my video tomorrow night.
All you have to do to participate is be a
subscriber and leave a comment.
So lots to talk about so here’s my top 5
moments, careful for spoilers if you haven’t
seen the episode.
Number 5 - Oberyn Martell and Tywin Come To
An Arrangement.
So many important things we learned from this.
Twyin believes in Daenerys dragons and flat
out denies any involvement in the death of
Oberyn’s sister.
But he only denies knowledge it happened.
Not that someone under him, like say The Mountain,
didn’t do it.
So he agrees to arrange a friendly chat between
Oberyn and said Mountain in exchange for sitting
on Tyrion’s trial.
And the seat on new King Tommen’s small
council.
There’s a small change from the books here.
Originally Tyrion had already offered the
seat on the small council in exchange for
Dorne’s help against Stannis during the
Battle of Blackwater.
Tywin’s also trying to use Joffrey’s Death
as a way to smooth things out with the Martells.
But I can’t wait to see Oberyn meet The
Mountain in combat.
How funny was it when Tywin just burst in
on Oberyn in the middle of that pile of flesh.
It reminded me of when Tyrion did the same
thing in episode 1.
There’s something about Lannisters walking
in on Oberyn while he’s humping people.
But I guess it seems like based on Oberyn’s
speech, he thinks every minute until old age
should be spent humping your brains out.
It was really nice of Twyin to call back to
the Martell’s being the only force to resist
the Aegon’s Conquest of Westeros.
I wonder if George RR Martin released that
Aegon excerpt last week because this shout
out from Tywin was happening in this episode?
Let me know if you agree.
Number 4 - Littlefinger Helps Sansa Escape
If you were clueing for looks into the mystery
of Joffrey’s death, I feel like Littlefinger
would just have a giant red flashing light
on his head.
He doesn’t out right say I was responsible
for everything.
But he did point out the fake necklace and
the fact that Ser Dontos was only doing what
he told him to do.
So it would have had to have all been Littlefinger’s
plan to incriminate Tyrion.
Even if the show is doing it differently from
the books, I don’t think it was that simple.
There will probably be more details in the
next episode.
Remember this though, Littlefinger always
reminds Sansa that everyone in the capital
is a liar, then promptly tells her she’s
safe with him and they’re heading home.
So right away giant red flashing warning lights
everywhere go off.
There was a clip of them on the boat in the
next episode, so I think they’ll show where
he’s taking her.
Did anyone else feel like Littlefinger was
laying on his Batman voice a little thick?
Who would ever trust someone that talked like
that?
Number 3 - Daario Vs The Champion of Meereen
So just a few minor changes from the books
because they cut out a few characters but
I thought this was an amazing way to show
off Daario’s skills and humor.
Like when they’re all listing their accomplishments
and Daenerys thinks they’re too precious
to fight.
So Daario is just like “I’m a nobody,
let me fight him”.
I am definitely like the new actor way more
than Ed Skrein, so I can’t wait to see more
of him when the story picks back up.
Did anyone get a Indiana Jones vibe with the
way he took down the Champion.
Especially with the way he chucked the knife
then turned around to face camera as if it
was no big deal.
Like in Raiders of the Lost Ark.
High fives to the writers and people that
filmed that scene.
Just awesome all around.
Number 2 - The Siege of Mereen
If you didn’t catch it right away she catapulted
all the old slaves collars over the wall as
proof of her intentions.
That she was going to break their chains.
They didn’t show a lot of them, but the
quote unquote masters are heads of the big
slaving families of Meereen.
We’ll probably meet them once Daenerys makes
it inside the walls.
We didn’t get a chance to see the Unsullied
in open combat last season, so seeing them
in formation launching those barrels was really
cool.
I’ll be interested to see if they change
anything in the next episode.
I think last season Barristan Selmy called
out Ser Jorah as a liar, but in this episode
Daenerys called him one of her most trusted
advisors.
She really laid it on thick, so I wonder if
that means something is going to happen between
them soon.
There were a ton of scenes in the trailer
with them inside the city walls.
So I don’t think he’s going anywhere anytime
soon.
Their ‘ship is still strong.
Stronger than Jaime and Cersei anyway.
Number 1 - Jaime takes Cersei right next to
Joffrey’s Corpse
I could spend an entire video about the many
things that happened in Baelor’s Sept.
First off, that was the Sept where Joffrey
just got married last week.
So that was a little creepy.
Then the burial rights with the coins on his
face with eyes drawn on.
Also creepy.
Did you notice how the camera just lingered
on him.
I’ll mention Tywin and Tommen during Bonus
moments, but the real moment was Cersei and
Jaime.
I think for the first time I can remember,
she openly calls out Joffrey to Jaime as their
son and demands he kill Tyrion.
Then he has his way with her and did you notice
how when they’re in the middle of all that
awfulness.
Joffrey’s face is clearly visible in the
frame.
Let me know if you were not shaking your head
in disgust.
I love how Game of Thrones does such a good
job of making you uncomfortable.
It also kind of seemed like Cersei was the
only one mourning Joffrey.
Even Twyin called him a terrible king when
he was talking to Tommen.
So here’s a couple bonus moments that we
also need to mention, but I didn’t think
were quite as important as my top 5.
Arya definitely looks like she’s losing
patience with the Hound.
I wonder if she’s just going to stick him
with Needle when she gets the chance.
Shireen and Davos’ letter to the Iron Bank
is a huge deal.
Remember the shot of the Titan of Braavos.
That’s a follow up on what’s going on
in this letter.
It’s Davos trying to get more ships and
men for Stannis.
I think Mark Gatiss is getting ready to make
his grand entrance.
Sam and Gilly were pretty adorable.
I really want those two to get a happy ending.
But I don’t think anyone on Game of Thrones
is allowed to have a happy ending.
I wonder if that’s part of George RR Martin’s
contract.
No Happy Endings.
Jon, Sam and Maester Aemon seem like the only
truly smart people at the Wall right now.
But I think they listened to Jon’s warning
about killing the mutinous Night’s Watch
brothers at Crasters to keep them from helping
Mance.
Either way Ygritte and those Thenn’s look
hungry for Crow.
Who else got a Tyrion Pod Sherlock and Watson
vibe.
Tyrion was clueing for looks as to who could
have killed Joffrey and who he could call
on to support him.
And then the sad goodbye.
Pod, this if Farewell.
and Let’s save all the Tommen and Tywin
talk for the comments.
Because that speech Twyin gave him was right
out of book 3, pretty much word for word.
But now it’s your turn, let me know what
your favorite WTF moment was.
Jaime and Cersei or any of the Daenerys Meereen
scenes?
They were all amazing, it’s hard to pick.
Overall, another solid A. I kind of worried
I’m going to end up giving all the episodes
this season an A minus or better.
So I’ll try to be more critical in the future.
But it’s hard to when everything is going
crazy in the best possible way.
I felt like the Sam Gilly scenes were the
weakest, but only because it seems like they’re
trying to set up a bigger side story for them.
If you got a creepy vibe from the stable he
took Gilly too you weren’t alone.
There’s no way she’s going to be safer
there.
I did love Sam’s reaction to “other work”.
Nope, no other work!
As for the cinematography and all the sets
I feel like I already speechified all my favorites
already.
Indiana Jones Daario and all.
Littlefinger’s ship did kind of remind me
of something from a pirate movie with all
that fog a silence.
I’ll only be rewatching it two more times,
tonight.
Let me know what your final verdict is and
what your big questions are.
I’m posting my Q&A video tomorrow night.
And announcing the round 3 giveaway winner.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
I think because Bran’s story is back I might
do that Bloodraven bonus video next week.
Right now click here for that Q&A, I’ll
add the annotation as soon as I post the video
and click here for my Purple Wedding video.
Ding Dong the witch is dead.
Thanks for watching everyone, see you tomorrow.
High Fives!